chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel looks at the controversy
surrounding this case there are now five
former Ohio State wrestlers accusing a
Republican Congressman Jim Jordan of
knowing about a team doctors alleged
sexual misconduct Jordan was an
assistant wrestling coach at Ohio State
more than 20 years ago
Fox has reviewed some of the emails
written by former wrestler Mike de
sabatoge Jordan including this one from
June 15th reverend james the
squeaky-clean US congressman from Urbana
who does not recall systemic sex abuse
he wants to Speaker of the House despite
his apparent lack of knowledge of
systemic sex abuse he concluded a May
sixth email with hashtag rape cover-up a
way of life the Sabbat old told Fox he
sent the emails to Jordan to help him
realize he needed a lead on what he
suggests was common knowledge it was an
uncomfortable joke that dockwood would
and wanted to give you a genital exam
every time you saw him Jordan denies
being aware of sexual abuse
he says the timing of the attacks is
suspicious right after the big hearing
with mr. Rosenstein it's right when
there's all this talk about speakers
race the law firm who was doing the
investigation
said they tried to contact us and we
didn't respond
we have no record emails obtained by Fox
show that law firm tried contacting him
at Jim Jordan at mail.house.gov which
his office says is a non-existent
account the congressman received full
support from President Trump on Air
Force One late yesterday quote Jim
Jordan is one of the most outstanding
people I've met since I've been in
Washington I believe him 100% with
lawmakers out of town it's been pretty
quiet but next week Jordan's colleagues
will be fielding many questions about
the congressman and this controversy
Brett
welcome Angela thank you